[Music]
starting off this hour
sammy in atlanta hi sammy welcome to the
ramsey show
hey thanks thanks dave thanks ken thanks
for taking my call sure what's up
hey um probably two years ago my wife
and i got serious about paying off our
eighty thousand dollar debt
um we're down to twenty nine thousand um
four years ago i left the public
teaching to go to private
so uh i left uh 30 000 in a trs fund and
kind of forgot about it
um so after four years it doesn't gain
um anything and i'm not contributing so
i have to move it over
so my wife and i want to know if we can
use that to
get six months ahead and pay the nine
thousand dollar penalty
and take that money and go ahead and be
debt-free
well you can but i wouldn't borrow money
at 30
interest to pay off your debt
correct
so i wouldn't i mean
you know if if you call me up said hey i
have a bank that'll loan me the money it
cost me nine
grand to borrow 30
so i can pay off this other debt and i'm
going to just pre-pay all the interest
nine grand
you wouldn't even ask me that question
right and it's the same thing dude
you're about to give the government a
third of your money for no apparent
reason other than you just want to be
out of debt really bad which i really
want you out of debt bad too but i don't
want you out of debt 33 percent bad
right it's just uh we're looking at
being able to uh
be six months ahead of the next step
which would be
more than the nine we would be losing
but it's still losing now
if i suggested to you that you borrow
money from a bank at 30
interest to pay off your debt and and
you said i don't want to do that and i
said the answer was
oh you're looking at six months you're
going to be out six months sooner you
would say
ramsay you've lost your dadgum mine
right but that was your comeback
yeah no i already knew the answer before
i actually called but
i decided to be this far along in the
journey
hey man i'm with you i want you out so
uh you're gonna be out you're gonna be
out it's just gonna be six months slower
and i'll give you a prediction it's
gonna be four months slower because
you're over this you're ready to be done
now take your old retirement and roll it
to an ira with a smartvestor pro don't
pay any taxes on it and let it grow from
this point without taxes
and you're going to love that you did
that later that's a better move long
term don't give the government a third
of your money
it just doesn't make sense and you can
ask the question six different ways and
i'm still gonna give you the same answer
every time that's the strange thing
about me ken
yeah you kind of know what you believe
why you believe it it's fairly
consistent
very consistent it's ridiculously boring
by the way that's a general rule of
thumb that's the correct answer and a
very specific answer to his question but
it's always a good rule of thumb to try
to avoid giving the government any of
your money
it's always a good place to start let's
just start and assume
they suck at handling money right so any
money any money you give to them
falls under the heading of bad
stewardship
god is not pleased no with me when i
send them money because they mishandle
it yeah
so and i'm not going to send it to
anybody else that mishandles it
either if i can help it so because it's
my
job is to handle it well yeah so yeah
they're they're they suck at
anything having to do with money just
it's that simple
there's not any you know how many times
do you hear the word government and
efficiency in the same sentence unless
there's an
in in front of it like in efficiency
yeah you just don't hear them in the
same sentence it doesn't come up so now
don't send the money
keep the money for yourself yes it's
always better
it's always better you're not being
patriotic it's just bad it's just ugly
don't don't send them money they're not
good with it yeah